What does Gwen Stefani, Mark Wahlberg,
Jonathan Roomie, Chris Pratt, and
several others, what do they have in
common? Well, they all are trying to put
out advertisements for an app called
Hallow.
>> Now, you don't know about Hallow prayer
app. Well, this Lent, I'd love to invite
you.
>> I'd love to invite you to join me.
>> You lead the Lent on Hallow this year.
You bet, brother. Hey, Chris. Join you
on Hallow.
>> Yes. Stay prayed up.
>> We also have Lauren Dagel. Of course, we
all pretty much in the Christian world
know her because she's a Christian
artist. But there's a recent development
there as well. She doesn't really want
to be considered a Christian artist, but
simply an artist. And she's also taken
some very interesting stances when it
comes to homosexuality. She's pretty
much become a supporter.
>> What do you call yourself?
>> I feel like those labels get put on you
by other people. I was reading one and
one of them's like Christian artists,
another one's just artists. So I think
part of me is just artist because it
encompasses everything. That's kind of
how I see myself. I didn't know that
Lent was a Christian thing. Where did
that come from? God tells us for one
that we are to look at people's fruit.
We look at Mark Wahberg's movies and one
good example is TED Unrated. It had a
lot of language, almost 300 fbombs
dropped in it. um has tons of drinking
and drugs and smoking, sex, romance,
nudity, um violence and scariness for a
little teddy bear guy that's joining
Mark Wahberg in his life doing all this
with him. So, it's really messed up.
Chris Pratt, Guardians of the Galaxy,
where they're literally gathered
together to fight against the creator
and ruler coming down in the skies, the
passenger. Uh he had a sex scene with
Jennifer Lawrence. This app, it was
featured on News Nation with Jonathan
Room as the creator, by the way. It has
become the biggest prayer app in the
entire world. He is a Knight's Templar.
>> I was uh kneded by the order, the solemn
uh sovereign military order of the
temple of Jerusalem. Lost my mind there
for a second. Um essentially the Knights
Templar Scully
got a brother. Yeah, that's his brother
Mory and Mary. That's Mary there. What
has happened with the morphing of Lent
into our society today? It's also called
Shrobe Tuesday, Martyra, Fat Tuesday. In
England, it's called Pancake Tuesday.
This overindulgence comes from honoring
the Roman festival god, fertility god,
sorry, lubricalia with feasting,
drinking, and carnal behaviors. This is
still what we have going on usually when
we have, you know, burning man, Marty
GR, all this stuff. And that's because
the celebrations today have an ancient
origin far removed from Christian
traditions.